so what can be done to more integrate
and what can I do for interior it's
interesting I'm the president of a
business school based in Central America
entire business school and we have
students from all over Latin America the
US or Europe some Asia that's not the
most important thing I personally do to
integrate this region is to connect
leaders young leaders who want to make a
future career in business and feature
for in a sustainable enterprise and who
get together and get to know each other
and that's by the way what motivates me
the most to another question that's what
really drives me every morning really
attracts me to try travel around the
region around the world to really
promote at the office of integrated
Latin America